there's a lesson here and I'm not the
one that's gonna figure it out don't
worry Rick that's why I'm here
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where I'd like to personally
congratulate Dan Harmon for finally
getting to work on a fourth season of
one of his shows I mean sure six seasons
in the movie didn't quite work out for
you but hey things are looking a bit
brighter when it comes to Rick and Morty
right Morty I mean that's a big promise
Stan but to be fair so few shows on
television right now combine such subtle
humor with big brain concepts that only
us with the highest of IQs can totally
understand so I can see it sticking
around for a long time and yes by the
way I do have my Rick and Morty tattoo
and no you cannot see it it's for the
ladies eyes only thank you very much so
season four just started and Rick and
Morty is back showing that it ain't
pullin any punches the season four
premiere Rick - I repeat is everything
that we've come to love about the show
hilarious what do you want meta you
ruined the season four premiere and most
importantly smart this episode throws a
lot at us and I mean a lot in this
single episode it does everything from
showing us a universe full of fascist
shrimp to Holograms gaining corporeal
forms to even referencing the anime
classic of a kid ah Oh real nice Rick
turning our son into an Akita leave it
to Jerry the Normie to go and ruin anime
for all of us and because it does throw
so much at us in this one episode it's
actually really easy to lose track of
what this episode is really all about
Rick even calls it out for us in the
episode almost like it's a challenge
there's a lesson here and I'm not the
one that's gonna figure it out so today
I wanted to try something new something
that's a little bit more laid back with
fewer edits a bit more of a casual
discussion not so much a theory as it is
an analysis of what this episode was
really all about
what was the season four premiere trying
to tell us because once you look past
all the body horror and skinny-dipping
this is a shockingly upbeat episode of
Rick and Morty and the message at least
the message as I see it is perhaps the
most humanitarian one that this show has
had to date the entire plot of the
episode seems to be based around two
conflicting ideas that send Rick Sanchez
and Morty Smith into diverging
directions it all starts when Rick takes
Morty on a mission to fetch some death
crystals rocks that when they're touched
give you a prophetic vision of your
future specifically the death II part of
your future death crystals show you how
you're gonna die your future stems from
your the present which if you're living
right keeps changing Rick of course only
wants the crystals to sell to the
highest bidder he doesn't want to know
his own destiny except what it helps him
to avoid death in the immediate present
I don't use them people that spend their
life avoiding death are already dead
they're also rich with their money
Rick's philosophy here boils down to one
key phrase truth is anyone that knows
how they're definitely gonna die is
either boring a chi double hockey sticks
Morty however seems to disagree ignoring
Rick's advice he decides to keep a death
crystal in his pocket and by touching it
he sees the various futures laid out
before him including one that involves
him dying of old age in the loving arms
of Jessica the girl he's had a crush on
since episode 1 Marty decides that this
is the death that he wants and he
decides to relentlessly pursue that
death by taking whatever steps necessary
that will cause him to have that fate
using the crystal in his pocket as a
compass every move he makes and every
word he says from that point forward is
directed towards that end goal which as
it turns out leads him to crashing the
space-cruiser and killing Rick in the
process and then not taking the steps
necessary to revive Rick luckily for
Rick operation Phoenix is still online
in other parts of the multiverse what
the heck I act this protocol oh and for
those of you who don't remember
operation Phoenix was actually the
protocol introduced in season 2 episode
big trouble in little Sanchez a
sort of immortality project for Rick to
be reborn into a clone body if his main
body ever bites the big one and yes he
did literally acts that program so he
gave the program the axe but Rick isn't
the only Rick in the multiverse so that
didn't stop him from being reincarnated
and cloned bodies that other rigs across
that multiverse were cultivating in
other dimensions rick and morty spend
the rest of the episode on their
separate adventures Morty relentlessly
follows whatever the death crystal tells
him will lead him to dying with Jessica
which includes a meeseeks filled rampage
and skipping a skinny dip with the girl
of his dreams I'm assuming we maybe get
together in our 40s eventually it all
ends with him turning himself into a
giant akira inspired goo monster in the
desert as he waits for further
instructions from the death crystal
shoutout to all the fans of classic 80s
anime out there Marty seems to be pretty
soulless and not to be fully enjoying
the present moment but hey you got to
secure that future with Jessica right
Rick meanwhile is off living and dying
in the present moment visiting a fascist
universe a fascist shrimp universe and a
fascist teddy bear universe the
cuddliest of all fascism before finally
being reincarnated into a lost body
which surprisingly turns out to be the
chillest of all the different dimensions
we eat our prey alive and when we don't
we lay our eggs in their eyeballs so
that our young can feast on their brains
when they hatch when you're born that
big a doodoo head the least you can do
is have a little empathy wasp Rick helps
our Rick get back home and together they
take down Morty in the desert freeing
him from the self-imposed bondage of the
death crystal after defeating an AI
hologram with a little help from wasp
Rick they all head home to not
contemplate the moral of today's story
there's a lesson here and I'm not the
one that's gonna figure it out okay
maybe they talked about it a little yes
I got to learn how to live in the moment
a little more oh boy so you actually
learned something today I was living in
the moment all day and I kept getting me
killed I think you have to think ahead
and live in the moment seems like a
pretty straightforward moral right the
constant dichotomy of living the moment
versus plan for the future and the
solution that they come to shockable
Sox's you need to do all things in
moderation you need a little bit of both
or at least that's what it appears to be
at first glance but there's actually
more to this philosophical debate than
meets the eye you see that isn't the
real message of this episode Brix
philosophy of living in the moment
actually sounds similar to the core
teachings of Zen Buddhism no I could
stand here and describe it for you but
British author tin lot actually sums it
up really well quote from him the
emphasis on the present moment is
perhaps Zen's most distinctive
characteristic in our Western
relationship with time in which we
compulsively pick over the past in order
to learn lessons from it and then
project into a hypothetical future in
which those lessons can be applied the
present moment has been compressed into
a tiny sliver on the clockface between a
vast past and an infinite future Zen
more than anything else is about
reclaiming and expanding the present
moment it tries to have you understand
that there is no purpose in getting
anywhere if when you get there all you
do is think about getting to some other
future moment life exists in the present
or nowhere at all this seems pretty
spot-on when it comes to Morty right
Morty is so obsessed with how he's gonna
die in this episode that he doesn't care
about how he's living I mean he's a
teenage boy who wants to wind up with
Jessica yet he turns down an opportunity
to spend more quality time with her and
her friends where he'll get to know them
all just a little bit better a bunch of
us girls were gonna go skinny-dipping
later if you wanted to join yeah he
would get to know them a little bit
better I am sure the conversations that
they would have had would have been very
meaningful anyway he pursues some vague
idea of this future happiness but in
doing so he ignores the happiness that's
sitting right in front of him undressing
itself and jumping into the nearest lake
in this way he is the antithesis of Zen
Buddhism teachings which is why Morty's
first words with the death crystal are
so ironic in this episode why don't you
do what I do and just go with the flow
nice and soon baby sorry Morty you're
not being Zen at all in fact Morty's
philosophy is probably closest to what's
known as objectivism
the idea that there are certain ultimate
objective truths and that those truths
supersede all of our subjective
experiences like perceptions emotions or
imagination for Morty his objective
truth in this episode is that dying with
Jessica and an old age is the best
possible wait and his life and rather
than trust his own feelings or instincts
morty follows the death crystal who
serves as his objective and impartial
guide to life sorry
oh damn Rick I'm going with the crystal
on this one - Morty everything else in
his world exists only to help him
towards making that future reality he
evaluates the moral rightness and
wrongness of each action based on
whether it's gonna lead him closer to
that end goal so allowing Rick to die
and stay dead
well it moves them closer to that
ultimate goal so it's okay same with
attacking bullies same with attacking
the police all of these are morally
reprehensible things but they become
morally justified under Morty's new
value system which only cares about one
thing whether or not it'll benefit him
and lead him to dying with Jessica in
his mind the ends justify the means
the show concludes by saying this I
think you have to think ahead and live
in the moment it makes it sound like
Rick and Morty's philosophies both have
problems that run in opposite directions
but in truth Rick and Morty are both
wrong for the exact same reason you see
both Rick and Morty fall victim to the
same trap and that trap is ethical
egoism it's not catchy in the slightest
ethical egoism is a theory a
consequentialist theory that the
consequences for any individual are the
thing that matter the most when
evaluating the morality of that
individual's choices now that sounds
really complex and confusing and it it
is when it's phrased that way but it's
really not that hard to understand so
let me simplify it in short egoism is
all about taking actions that benefit
you even if they might be hurtful to
others so Rick taking Morty on deadly
adventures example of egoism Morty
vaporizing bullies because he wants to
get with Jessica egoism if that sounds
like an inherently self
potentially dangerous philosophy with
which to look at the world well you're
not wrong but it is founded on a
reasonable core principle right the fact
that each individual person is the best
expert on how to make themselves happy
by allowing everyone to be free to
pursue whatever makes them happy in life
well everyone will just take care of
their own happiness and society will be
all the better for it that's the idea
but I think you can probably see a
couple problems with it right if you're
only looking out for your own
self-interest those interests might wind
up being detrimental to others I mean in
a Rick and Morty context just look at
what makes chrome Bob ulis Michael happy
hi Morty I'm crumb bomb polish Michael
I'm an assassin I just love killing if
he's set free on society out to pursue
his own happiness means a lot of other
people are gonna have their happiness
prematurely cut off the episode makes it
seem like the solution is to find a
compromise between the extremes of plan
for the future and live in the present
moment but both Rick and Morty missed
the point it's not about either of those
things it's not about planning for the
future or living in the moment it's
about not being a selfish jerk in the
immediate not being a pure egomaniac
Morty throughout the episode is willing
to do whatever it takes to achieve his
goal in the long term but the same is
true for Rick in the short term Rick
throughout the episode is willing to do
whatever it takes to get himself home
even if it means piling wasp Hitler
wah Spitler look I'm a primate I'm
having a hard time I'll think or say
whatever gets me home wasp Hitler we'll
see if that's a search term that flags
YouTube's algorithms it's the same
consequentialist theory egoism what
eventually saves both Rick and Morty
isn't learning to plan for the future
but learning the importance of empathy
from wasp Rick well here's how it works
with wasps we eat our prey alive and
when we don't we lay our eggs in their
eyeballs so that our young can feast on
their brains when they hatch when you're
born that big a jerk the least you can
do is have a little empathy it's that
moment of empathy from wasp Rick that
allows our Rick to eventually return
home and it's that empathy that he
learns that gets him to save and care
for Morty I mean look at how caring and
gentle he is to Morty when he's rescued
from the akhirah monster he has never
expressed that level of care to Morty
and yet here it is on full display
Morty similarly has an eye-opening
revelation in the post-credits scene
when he learns that the future he
foresaw this entire time was actually
just a vision of him dying without any
friends or family with Jessica working
as a hospice nurse who stayed with him
simply because he had no other loved
ones there to comfort him Rick doesn't
abandon his philosophy of living in the
moment and Morty doesn't have to abandon
his philosophy of planning for the
future instead both of them learn to see
outside of their own self-interest
ultimately whether you prioritize the
present or plan for the future doesn't
matter if you're only focused on
selfishly serving yourself it'll lead
you down a path of destruction sure all
that talk about living in the moment
versus plan for the future may have been
a point a point to the episode but it
wasn't the point of the episode in the
end what really matters is about
balancing your own interest with the
needs of the world around you which
feels like an especially pointed message
considering some members of the Rick and
Morty fandom have sometimes gotten a bit
of a toxic label in their behavior
bullying others trash
McDonald's for Szechuan sauce I mean it
is a message that's buried under a lot
of layers in this episode but you know
the Rick and Morty fandom has super high
IQs so they'll get it but hey what just
think of this new more laid-back style
did you like it not I'd love your
thoughts so let me know down in the
comments section below and while you're
down there clearly telling me how much
you loved this episode special thank you
to our sponsor for today audible for
making it happen
and I mean that in a very literal way
audible which as I'm sure you know by
now is the best option for all your
audiobook needs helps me do research for
these episodes much faster because I'm
able to listen to audiobooks everywhere
while I'm at work while I'm playing with
Oliver while I'm driving through LA
suddenly that time has a double use I'm
accomplishing the task at hand but I'm
also using that time to research and
learn and for this episode in particular
I specifically listened to Zen Zen for
beginners as well as a concise history
of Buddhism because I a fan of Rick and
Morty am an intellectual who listens to
that sort of stuff regularly in my spare
time but seriously we are all busy
people we don't have time to sit down
and read books but at the same time who
wants to just stop learning right well
audible is the solution for us it's the
optimized way for us busy people to keep
up with the latest releases from our
favorite authors the sequel to
Handmaid's Tale the testament Foom
listen to it with audible and now is the
best time to get your membership with a
special offer of 53 percent off your
first three months because why settle
for half when you can go above and
beyond that is just 695 a month for
audiobook goodness poured into your
earholes you get three titles every
month one audiobook and two exclusive
audible originals that you can't hear
anywhere else don't like the book well
they have an easy audio book exchange
and for the ones that you do end up
loving you keep that audio book library
forever even if you cancel so give
yourself or Peck another super-smart
person in your life the gift of
listening this holiday season just go to
audible.com slash film theorists or
click the top line in the description
because film theorists is way too long
to type in yourself that's audible.com
slash film theorists and start
optimizing your listening experience
today